[Music]
tonight allows people a release for all
the hatred and violence if they keep up
inside them this won't bring him back
it won't make you feel any better thank
you it is a night that is defining our
country citizens this will be a
tradition we celebrate every year join
the first purge how do you think says
always see tonight people are now
calling this controversial experiment of
legalized crime the purge you and Isaiah
just stay with me doing approach oh
we're gonna be fine on how we are here
with dr. may up Dale she came up with
this experiment is the purge a political
device it is a psychological one if we
want to save our country we must release
all our anger in one night tonight we'll
see the good and evil in everyone this
is your emergency broadcast system
announcing the commencement of the first
purge our neighborhood is under siege
from a government who doesn't give a
[ __ ] about any of us at the siren all
crime including murder will be legal for
12 hours there's a lot of good people
with out there who we gonna have to
protect you all emergency services will
be suspended we got to be prepared for
anything your government thanks you for
your participation parties you predicted
a much higher level of participation
human nature does not obey the laws of
politics
what the hell is going on
they all ex-military some funky going
down deep you're sending soldiers into
the island disguised as citizens this
country needs for this door
what was coming to help us after tonight
nothing will ever be the same again they
forgot about one thing they forgot about
us what have I done thanks your honor
I'm coming
just remember all the good the purge
does
[Music]